investors begin dumping stocks as the
federal reserve announces a rate hike
joe biden plans cryptocurrency
regulations and the media tries to
pretend that joe biden's black female
supreme court pick isn't about race or
sex i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
bureau show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up against big tech
protect your data at expressvpn.com
ben will get to all the news in just one
moment first how would you like a signed
copy of my newest book hot off the press
the authoritarian moment how'd you like
a copy of that book and protect your
savings from a repeat of carter era
inflation honestly you're not just going
to buy birch gold to get a copy of my
book you're doing it to protect yourself
against the vicissitudes of government
regulators birch gold will help you
convert an eligible ira or 401k into an
ira backed by real gold which does
provide peace of mind that's why i am a
birch gold customer i've been investing
in gold with them for a very long time
at least a part of your portfolio should
be in something that is not controlled
directly by the federal government and
that means something like precious
metals their gold ira experts are
extremely knowledgeable which is why
they have thousands of satisfied
customers in a plus rating with the
better business bureau you can trust
birch gold to help you protect your
savings today text ben to 98 98 98 to
get a free information kit on buying
gold in a tax sheltered account and when
you buy before the end of the month
birch gold will send you a signed copy
of my brand new book the authoritarian
moment text ben
298-9898 to get your free information
kit right now again tech spend to 98 98
98 to get all the information you need
for my friends over at birch gold
alrighty so the biden economy is now
hitting the skids it is hitting the
skids because we had a super heated
economy in which we were pouring
trillions of dollars on top of an
economy that really didn't need it the
fact is that when the pandemic first
started and the government told
everybody to go home from work there was
a case to be made that the government
had essentially driven a ford f-150 into
your business and now they had to pay
recompense for that but as it became
quickly cleared what the government
really needed to do was first take the
ford f-150 out of the front of your
business and allow you to reopen your
business it became just as clear that
what the government shouldn't do is
after rectifying the expense continue to
pay you just so that they could leave
the ford 150 directly in the middle of
your business once it was clear that
businesses ought to be reopened and that
young healthy people were going to be
generally fined from covid the
government ought to have gotten out of
the business of quote unquote
stimulating the economy instead the
federal reserve bought up every asset it
could find it started injecting
trillions of dollars into the economy
many people finished the pandemic with
more in savings than they had at the
beginning which is amazing since a huge
number of people went completely
unemployed during that time but again
the government was literally paying
people to stay home for large periods of
time
this led to overheated inflation
dramatic lack of supply and tremendous
price squeezes well now the federal
reserve is about to end america's era of
easy money according to the wall street
journal that is prompting investors to
reverse course on two years of investing
strategies kicking off this month's
broad market route the worst sell-off
since the early days of the pandemic
major u.s stock indices have dropped
between 6 and 15 percent in january
through thursday with some investor
favorites during the pandemic like
moderna peloton and netflix falling
around two or three times as much wall
street's fear gauge the siboe volatility
index of expected market swings has
almost doubled this year some well-known
hedge funds are down 10 or more said
people familiar with the results driving
the tumultuous expectations the fed will
raise interest rates for the first time
since 2018 likely setting off a series
of increases over the next couple of
years on wednesday fed officials gave
their clearest indication they could
boost rates in march and beyond at the
same time government policies to put
money in the pockets of consumers are
waning
in response investors are changing
strategies they've ridden hard for
almost two years rattling stocks bonds
and cryptocurrencies all of which soared
during the age of pandemic stimulus you
can see why people really had no place
to be if you left their money in the
bank this was a complete waste of time
so people started buying stocks like
crazy they started putting their money
in bonds to a lesser extent and they
started putting their money in crypto to
hedge against that inflation
girding themselves against the impact of
tighter money investors are shifting to
investments that feel safer such as
dividend stocks and gold exchange traded
funds indeed some high dividend funds
have outperformed this year including
the investor high yield equity dividend
achievers etf which is flat so far in
january individuals were big purchasers
of hot stocks and bullish call options
which gave holders the right but not the
obligation to buy shares at a certain
price are also reversing their approach
some are dabbling in broad market index
funds as well as bearish put options
which can further right to sell shares
at a stated price by specified date so
people are banking on the idea that the
stock market is now going to correct and
stabilize or go down over the course of
the next few months
while higher interest rates as the wall
street journal aren't likely to
seriously crimp economic growth at least
over the next few months a turnaround in
investor attitudes is already being felt
and is likely to continue to ripple
through markets in unpredictable ways
people's bank accounts surged many put
that money into the market the stimulus
has ended rising rates are likely said
rob arnot founding chairman of research
affiliates an asset management firm
based in newport beach california this
week hedge fund investor william ackman
said his firm had acquired 3.1 million
shares of netflix after the stock's
recent tumble
mr arnott and others urged caution he
said sell the surges don't buy the
depths
okay but here's the reality if you've
lost money on your stocks hold on to
them if you can right don't sell them as
as long as you can never sell when the
market is going down is you know the
first rule of investing
okay but with that said the s p 500 and
the dale are now on track for their
fourth weekly loss according to the wall
street journal futures for the s p 500
waiver falling 0.5 percent the benchmark
gauge of large cap stocks has fallen 1.6
for the week putting it on course for
its longest losing streak since
september of 2020. futures for the
technology technology-focused nasdaq 100
slipped 0.1 percent contracts for the
dow jones industrial average fell 0.6
chevron reported its most profitable
year since 2014 said it would raise
capital expenditures by 20 to 15 billion
dollars this year shares fell 1.6 in
pre-market trading anyway
caterpillar edged down after the company
reported a surging cost offsetting a
jump in revenue apple shares did rise
4.1 ahead of the bell after the biggest
u.s company by market cap posted record
revenue and profits shares of robin hood
markets which reported a quarter
quarterly loss of 423 million dollars
dropped 14
in pre-market trading and of course
chairman jerome pell added to
expectations the central bank will start
a series of interest rate increases in
march
now here is the thing
the u.s economy is experiencing very
strong growth however that growth is
paired with extraordinary inflation
and that again is because
of government policy inflation as milton
friedman once said is anywhere and
everywhere a monetary phenomenon
according to the wall street journal the
us economy grew rapidly in the fourth
quarter of last year advancing to a 6.9
percent annual rate a growth has run
into obstacles that could lead to more
modest growth this year as the economy
so you're looking for a slowing economy
this year gdp he brought us measures of
goods and services in the fourth quarter
accelerated from the third quarter's
growth of 2.3 adjusted for inflation
the gain reflected solid spending by
households much of it occurring early in
the quarter
output grew 5.5 percent in all of 2021
when comparing the fourth quarter to the
same period a year earlier the economy
has not grown that fast since 1984
there's only one problem inflation has
not grown this fast since 1982 so
all of the gains have basically been
eaten up by the inflationary numbers
andrew hunter chief u.s economist at the
research from capital economics says the
headline 6.9 figure is probably a bit
overly optimistic in terms of the
underlying strength of demand we do
think it's increasingly clear that the
case that the economy is essentially at
or rapidly approaching that capacity
constrained potential level the speed
limit is lower now than it was before
the pandemic
two factors that helped drive last
year's expansion the torrents of cash
sent from congress to households and the
ultra low borrowing costs stoked by the
fed are fading households have spent
down some of their stimulus money and
again it's the underlying economic
activity that matters because when you
decide that the economy is basically
about how the federal reserve is going
to take in money and then
gush out money that is not about
underlying economic activity the
underlying economic activity has to be
based on innovation it has to be based
on people creating new services and
products and selling those and competing
this is how economies grow they don't
grow just because the federal reserve
takes in money and then breathes it back
out again in a sort of reverse osmosis
osmosis process with regard to the
monetary supply
it happens to be the case according
again to the wall street journal that
the cost of hiring new employees and
retaining existing ones in the nation's
tight labor market
is now growing at nearly its fastest
pace in a generation that's helping to
fuel inflation as employers pass labor
costs to customers
at the u.s employment cost index a
quarterly measure of wages and benefits
paid by employers is expected to show
that costs continue to rise at the
highest rate in two decades of available
records so it could be even more because
this only goes back a couple of decades
economists surveyed by the wall street
journal expect a seasonally adjusted
increase of 1.2 percent in the fourth
quarter of 2021 over the prior three
months which experienced a similar
increase the third quarter gain when
compared with the same quarter from a
year earlier rose 3.7 percent
labor costs are a significant
contributor rising prices the current
tight labor market is encouraging many
workers with bargaining power to switch
jobs and demand more pay raising the
risk of destabilizing inflation dynamic
knows known as a wage price spiral in
which the prices go up so people need
more money for their wages and then the
wages go up so the producers have to
have to charge more money for the
product and her is an executive director
at ihm ihs market says quote inflation
has fundamentally picked up i think it's
fair to say price gains are feeding back
into wage gains there's a lot of
pressure on the supply side on both
commodities and labor
investors and the federal reserve now
consider the labor market to be at or
near full employment despite the fact
that the economy has only recovered
about 84 of the jobs it had before the
pandemic
so 16 of the jobs we had before the
pandemic are still gone the labor force
has dramatically shrunk with the
unemployment rate now below four percent
the fed is shifting gears from providing
stimulus to the economy to fighting
inflation while trying to maintain the
labor market recovery
jerome powell says we are attentive to
the risks that persistent real wage
growth in excess of productivity could
put upward pressure on inflation
so as the wall street journal points out
none of this was necessary we could have
just had a normal economic recovery and
everything would have been fine if joe
biden and the federal reserve had left
everything alone but they didn't
as the wall street journal editorial
page points out imagine if the biden
administration had focused primarily on
the pandemic as it took power a year ago
get the vaccines out accelerate coveted
therapies let an economy poise to soar
take off on its own no 1.9 trillion
relief bill in march no threat of new
tax increases and spending to quote
unquote transform american society would
the economy now be healthier with much
less inflation fewer shortages and more
consumer and business confidence we'll
never know but there's a strong case for
thinking so
the bureau of economic analysis says the
gdp expanded 5.7 in 2021 which is the
fastest annual growth since the 80s but
the recovery from the pandemic was
always going to take off politicians
shut the economy down from much of 2020
then poured cash into consumer pockets
to compensate and the federal reserve
flooded the economy with more money a
boom for the ages was poised to happen
in 2021 no doubt the biden
administration would take credit in the
event the economy in 2021 did not grow
nearly as fast or in as healthier
fashion as it should have that is clear
from the details of growth in the fourth
quarter top line growth of 6.9 was
robust accelerating from 2.3 in the
third quarter but by far the biggest
contributor to gdp 4.9 percentage points
was a buildup of inventories this means
retailers and other businesses were
restocking empty shelves not making
sales
there's probably more inventory build up
to come due to shortages across the
economy but that fourth quarter increase
is unsustainable in other words what
happened is there was a backlog of
products okay and so everybody produced
in order to put those products on the
shelves but that pace is not going to
continue because now everybody's got
their product right it's going to come
off the shelves and people don't need
the second product they already got the
first product so all that happened is
there was a massive buildup of economic
growth that happened to sort of
materialize in the fourth quarter
according to the wall street journal
editorial board consumer spending
contributed 2.25 percentage points much
of that came came from spending down
accumulated savings from the government
largesse the personal savings rate fell
to 7.4 percent from 9.5 in the third
quarter real disposable income after
inflation fell 5.8 percent in the fourth
quarter after falling 4.3 in the third
real disposable income is down 5.8
percent in the fourth quarter after
falling 4.3 in the third okay that means
that people are spending down all the
money that they got from the government
and they're gonna run out soon
the white house hailed the gdp growth
figure but if times are so good why do
the polls give the economy low marks and
buy them little credit
the best explanation is inflation
running at seven percent in the consumer
price index
even the fed's preferred inflation
measure personal consumption
expenditures rose at an annual rate of
6.5 percent in the fourth quarter
accelerating from 5.3 percent in the
third quarter
this is where focus on covid's strategy
would have helped
the march spending blowout caused a
surge in a man that met with a historic
supply shortage and then the uncertainty
from the proposed buildback better tax
increases and vows to punish businesses
with new regulation added to the supply
problems because why would you invest
into a market that was going to tax the
living hell out of you none of this was
necessary
so what is the bind administration going
to do about all of this their plan
apparently is to regulate bitcoin
not kidding okay so to understand what
bitcoin and crypto are essentially
bitcoin and crypto have
a couple of main purposes one is
financial security that does not require
verifiability from a financial
institution right normally when you use
your credit card they're like seven or
eight actual layers intermediaries
between the person to whom you are
giving the money and you they're a bunch
of verifiability companies companies
that verify that your credit card
transaction is correct the credit card
company having to deal with your bank in
order to actually convey the money right
the credit card company doesn't just
have all of your money on hand the bank
has to pay the credit card company the
credit card company then pays the person
to whom you're paying et cetera okay
they're like seven or eight
intermediaries
what what the
financial innovation part of bitcoin is
what cryptocurrencies do is they cut
that out they create a trustless system
because what crypto
what cryptocurrency does it creates
something called the blockchain the
blockchain is a bunch of people who are
sitting in rooms cracking codes the
reason that they are cracking the codes
is when they crack a code they have
verified that your exchange is proper so
they can trace every dollar that is
being sent via cryptocurrency from one
place to another place and verify that
it's not just fake money that's being
made up and transferred that is what the
blockchain is this is what
cryptocurrency miners do what they do is
they just verify the blockchain that's
all they do all day long okay so that's
one purpose the other purpose is that
cryptocurrencies
have a limited amount of supply
meaning that it's not affected by the
federal reserve it's not the federal
reserve saying we need a hotter economy
just pump some money into crypto that is
not how that works cryptocurrency has a
set amount of supply this is the magic
of cryptocurrency just like gold or
silver just like any other hard asset
cryptocurrency cannot be manipulated by
outside forces who just blow up the
amount of cryptocurrency in circulation
and therefore devalue the cryptocurrency
that you have in your pocket
now the catch with cryptocurrency is
that the value of cryptocurrency is
largely dependent on how many people are
into it right it's like stocks it
depends on how many people want it at
any given time so when the dollar seems
more solid fewer people are going to
invest in cryptocurrency which is what
you've been seeing over the last couple
of months as cryptocurrencies have seen
a bunch of people sell off and you've
seen it go from a high of 65 000 down to
the mid-30s there's a lot of volatility
in the crypto market because there are
not enough players in the crypto market
as of yet
so what this means that basically
cryptocurrency is good for two purposes
one is a repository of value and second
as a as an actual currency that can be
used in exchange the problem with using
it as a currency is in exchange is that
when the value of cryptocurrency varies
that widely
would you as a as a say car dealership
owner wants to take crypto in payment
for your car when that crypto could be
worth half of what it is today tomorrow
and the answer generally is no as crypto
gains broader and broader market
acceptance however that could change and
as blockchain technology gains broader
and broader usage that's going to cut
out a bunch of those intermediaries that
we've been talking about
the biggest victims of cryptocurrency
are centralized government bureaucracies
the federal reserve hates
cryptocurrencies the reason that the
federal reserve hates cryptocurrencies
is because they provide a hedge against
the the federal government being able to
inflate and deflate your savings
because again unlike the federal reserve
there is no centralized power that is in
control of the amount of cryptocurrency
in circulation when the federal reserve
wants to decrease the value of the
dollar all they have to do is buy up a
bunch of assets from the market and
inject money into the circulation flow
of the economy
and when they want there to be less
money in circulation they attempt to
sell off as much as they possibly can
which is what you are seeing right now
they can also monkey around with the
overnight interest rates that banks
charge to other banks when they have to
fill in their ledgers
and that none of that happens with
cryptocurrency so what this means is
that if you're joe biden and you are
heavily reliant on government
manipulation of the currency markets in
order for you to be able to pursue your
agenda if you want the government to
have complete control over everybody's
savings what you really want to do is
centralize more of that control crypto
is a threat to that and this is why the
biden administration in the middle of
economic turmoil is now talking about
heavy regulations on crypto because what
they don't want is a parallel shadow
economy arising that they cannot control
so this is why today the white house
announced that they want crypto rules as
a matter of national security they're
calling it a national security issue the
claim being that because they're usually
banks that are intermediaries between
payments this allows them to for example
monitor terrorist transactions and if
you get rid of all the intermediaries
then terrorists can transfer money
across borders without having to worry
about any of those institutions
verifying the transaction
okay but that's not all they're trying
to regulate here they're really this
this really is not about national
security again one of the things about
cryptocurrencies that's kind of amazing
is you can actually trace every single
dollar because the blockchain is
accessible you can see how these
transactions work
well according to behrens the biden
administration is preparing to release
an executive action that will task
federal agencies with regulating digital
assets like bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies as a matter of national
security a person familiar with the
white house's plan tells barons
only the federal government can send
pallets of cash to iran you however
cannot conduct a cross-border
transaction in crypto to buy a product
from say mexico
the national security memorandum
expected to come in the next few weeks
would task parts of the government with
analyzing digital assets and assembling
a regulatory framework that covers
cryptos stable coins and nfts or
non-fungible tokens this person said the
person said this is designed to look
holistically at digital assets and
develop a set of policies that give
coherency to what the federal government
is trying to do in this space the state
department treasury department national
economic council and council of economic
advisors would be involved in this
initiative
the white house national security
council would also be involved the
person said since crypto has economic
implications for national security along
these lines the administration would
instruct agencies to work on harmonizing
regulations of digital assets between
countries
so they're looking for an international
regime of cryptocurrency control if you
think that these governments are deeply
concerned about the passage of money for
terrorist purposes you got another thing
coming that's not what this is about
first of all the number one asset that
people actually use to conduct black
market transactions is cold hard cash
right they actually use just american
dollars for example which is why in
every crime movie you've ever seen
somebody shows up with a briefcase full
of actual cash
so maybe they should crack down on
american dollars and the usage of cash
by the way they are attempting to do
this because they actually want to trace
all your transactions as well the white
house wouldn't issue recommendations
agencies would be given three to six
months to come up with proposals as the
white house would act as a policy
coordinator the white house declined to
comment
the white house aims to bring order to
that haphazard approach that the
government is now using to regulate
crypto the person said various agencies
oversee the industry including the sec
the commodities future trading
commission there's no consensus on
matters such as whether some tokens
should be registered as securities or
how to oversee exchanges stable coins
and high-yield lending products
the bite administration wants congress
to draft rules the white house released
a report on stable coins in november
recommending the congress act promptly
to regulate the industry the federal
reserve is also weighing in on digital
currencies there's a shock the fed
released a report on a central bank
digital currency or cbdc earlier in
january that laid out the pros and cons
of digitizing the dollar the report said
the fed could start working on the
project with support from the white
house in congress here's the problem
once the fed digitizes the dollar they
can inflate or deflate the currency with
literally the push of a button they can
just push a button and they can make
money appear or disappear and if you
start to have the federal reserve acting
as your banker and you're going to store
your digital money with the federal
reserve do you really want jerome powell
and control that directly of your assets
and you want them regulating cryptos
that you are forced into the federal
reserve currency
they get rid of things like bitcoin and
instead what they like they choke it off
and instead they say if you want to be
involved in a digital currency without
the market transactional cost of using a
credit card then what you really need to
do is you need to head on over to the
federal reserve so they're in complete
control of your savings
there's a reason they're doing this it
is always and forever about control in
just one second we get to the proof of
that when paul kergmann endorses an idea
that's how you know it's a stupid idea
we'll get to that in just one moment
first with the ever-increasing number of
car makes and models it is now
impossible to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain storefront
why endure the often pointless or
seemingly intimidating questions about
the specifications of your vehicle only
to have the counterman or the parts on
his computer anyway you have computers
with access to rockauto.com at home and
in your pocket
why would you choose to spend 30 50 100
more for the exact same auto parts at a
chain store or a new car dealership
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers they have
everything from engine control modules
and brake parts to tail lamps motor oil
even new carpet whether it's for a
classic or daily driver get everything
you need and a few easy clicks deliver
directly to your door best of all the
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts amazing selection reliably low
prices all the parts your car will ever
need rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
usbox so they know that we sent you
again that is rockauto.com
alrighty so paul krugman is coming out
strong against cryptocurrencies which is
not a shocker paul krugman suggests that
it's just like a subprime mortgage
it's not just like a subprime mortgage
subprime mortgages were subsidized by
the federal government the subprime
mortgage industry arose because the
federal government essentially said they
were going to backstop a bunch of
mortgages they knew were going to go
broke and then they were hoping that the
market just kept increasing so that
people could sell off their houses if
they do if they did go broke the
subprime mortgage crisis was created by
government policy designed to make sure
that people who could not pay their
mortgages got mortgages this was the
explicit goal of the subprime mortgage
market and then the market started
playing with those and packaging those
subprime mortgages with other mortgages
and mixing in toxic toxic assets with
non-toxic assets
and creating all sorts of derivative
arrangements and those derivative
arrangements then had infectious effects
throughout the economy in 2007-2008 but
the key problem with subprime is that
there were a bunch of people who could
not afford houses who were being granted
subprime mortgages on the basis of zero
or no credit history because the federal
government was subsidizing that
paul krugman however is trying to
compare crypto to subprime which again
makes no sense crypto is based on you
literally taking your money and buying a
product
and now you own the product the product
is crypto
it is not alone it's not government
subsidized in fact the government very
much tries to shut down crypto
but according to paul krugman they're
exactly the same why because anything
that he can use as an excuse to crack
down on a particular practice he will so
never mind that paul krugman had nothing
to say about the real estate bubble that
was being created by the federal reserve
and the federal government fannie mae
and freddie mac
during the 2000 so far as i'm aware
it doesn't matter that he he's very much
in line with the idea that the federal
government should be subsidizing low
low rate mortgages to people of minority
background who can't actually pay those
mortgages
he says this is just like crypto because
if subprime is bad and crypto is bad
this means they're the same
so paul krugman who is just it's insane
this guy won a nobel prize i mean he won
a nobel prize for trade policy and then
he proceeded to just blabber about
everything else that he has no idea what
he's talking about it's really
incredible
he's it's it's amazing the ultra
crepitarianism the speaking out of out
of turn by paul krugman on these issues
is pretty astonishing he says if the
stock market isn't the economy which it
isn't really and cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin really really aren't the economy
still crypto has become a pretty big
asset class and yielded huge capital
gains to many buyers by last fall the
combined market value of crypto had
reached almost three trillion dollars
since then however prices have crashed
wiping out around 1.3 trillion dollars
in market capitalization as of thursday
morning bitcoin's price was almost
halfway down from its november peak so
who's being hurt by this crash and what
might it do to the economy well first of
all anytime the economy goes down the
people who are at the margins of the
economy do the worst
this is true forever it's true in the
stock market the stock market has taken
a dump over the last month the people
who are hurt the worst are the people in
pension funds the the people who have
taken their little bit of savings and
put in the stock market
and people have a lot of money in the
stock market are fine they'll just ride
it out
so i'm not sure why paul krugman thinks
that crypto is any different and i own
crypto i'm fine i'll just wait i won't
sell it right now because i'm not an
idiot i basically bought it around where
it is right now
okay so i'll just wait for it to go back
up again
but according to paul krugman
crypto innately targets the most
vulnerable which he's gonna have to
explain
he says i'm seeing uncomfortable
parallels with the subprime crisis of
the 2000s no crypto doesn't threaten the
financial system the numbers aren't big
enough to do that but there's growing
evidence the risks of crypto are falling
disproportionately on people who don't
know what they are getting into and are
poorly positioned to handle the downside
my favorite thing about paul krogman is
that he thinks that if the government
tells you what to do with your money you
will do better and then after the
government tells you what to do with
your money and sponsors financial
products like subprime mortgages and
everything goes south the solution is
the government needs to step in and do
something about it
there is no falsifiability to any of
paul krugman's theses about exactly how
the government's involvement in the
economy is good
he says what's this crypto thing about
there are many ways to make digital
payments from apple pay and google pay
to venmo mainstream payment schemes
however rely on a third party usually
your bank to verify you actually own the
assets you're transferring
cryptocurrencies use complex codings to
supposedly do away with the need for
these third parties not not supposedly
they do
i mean the cryptocurrencies have been
used all over the world
skeptics wonder why this is necessary
and i argue that crypto ends up being an
awkward expensive way to do things you
could have done more easily in other
ways which is why cryptocurrencies still
have few legal applications 13 years
after bitcoin was introduced well no the
real reason that they have few legal
applications is because the government
actively discourages people from
investing in bitcoin and until bitcoin
reaches critical mass where a huge
number of people own it
it's gonna be very difficult to use it
as an actual asset that is tradable on
on markets right there are certain
countries like el salvador which has
started using crypto as a medium of
exchange they're first into the ball
game
but the the reality is that as long as
crypto is this volatile again people are
not going to use it as a medium of
exchange
so says paul krugman crypto has crashed
now maybe it will recover and sort new
heights as it has in the past for now
however prices are way down who are the
losers
as i said there are disturbing echoes of
the subprime crash 15 years ago crypto
is unlikely to cause an overall economic
crisis it's a big world out there even
one three one point three trillion
dollars in losses is only about six
percent of us at gdp a hit that's an
order of magnitude smaller than the
effects of falling home prices when the
housing bubble burst and activities like
bitcoin mining while environmentally
destructive are economically trivial
compared with home building whose
plunged played played a large role in
causing the great recession still some
people are being hurt who are they
according to a survey by the research
organization nork 44 of crypto investors
are non-white 55 percent don't have a
college degree this matches up with
anecdotal evidence that crypto investing
has become remarkably popular among
minority groups and the working class
you want to know why because they're a
bunch of people who can't actually open
bank accounts because they don't have
enough assets so instead they take their
money they put it in crypto and then
they can actually transfer money between
themselves using crypto wallets that's
why they don't wish to pay the credit
card intermediaries so instead they use
crypto okay that is why
what crypto does it it alleviates the
need to have an actual bank account this
is why there are people living in
afghanistan right now who are using
crypto in order to trade currency in
order to pay for things
newark says this is great that
cryptocurrencies are opening up
investing opportunities for more diverse
investors but i remember the days when
subprime mortgage lending was similarly
celebrated and when it was hailed as a
way to open up the benefits of home
ownership to previously excluded groups
yeah the difference is again the federal
government was subsidizing the sub-prime
mortgages it was the federal government
and people like paul krugman pushing it
saying that this is good
crypto isn't good because more
minorities are participating in it
crypto is good so more minorities are
participating in it
so he's afraid that people are getting
into crypto not understanding what it is
okay well how many people understand the
stock market super well
really how many people how many people
understand what the federal reserve does
if you took a poll of the average
american do you think they understand
what the federal reserve does or the
relationship between the federal reserve
and quantitative easing and the buying
and selling of bonds via the treasury
but like how many people you think
actually understand that paul yeah
people are invested in the dollar and
the stock market the proof is in the
pudding people invest in products when
they think that they will make money
from those products
and paul krugman's assessment that
people don't have enough information
about crypto and so crypto is bad really
is because paul krugman has trust in
government officials to control the
currency
he says maybe those of us who still
can't see what crypto cryptocurrencies
are good for other than money laundering
and tax evasion are just missing the
picture you you are you don't know
anything just maybe the rising valuation
of bitcoin and its rivals represents
something more than a bubble in which
people buy an asset simply because other
people have made money off that asset in
the past it's okay for investors to bet
against skeptics but these investors
should be people who are both
well-equipped to make that judgment and
financially secure enough to bear the
losses if it turns out the skeptics are
right
he says regulators have made the same
mistake they made on subprime they
failed to protect the public against
financial products nobody understood
everybody understood subprime
they just didn't think that the market
was going to go down
and i i love the innate racism of paul
krugman here he's like you know there
are a bunch of minority people who have
this crypto thing and uh and they
shouldn't be allowed to have those
crypto things now without the government
getting involved because they're stupid
and they don't know things i mean he
literally says 44 of crypto investors
are non-white and then he's like also we
need to regulate crypto because stupid
people are getting involved in dude
that's kind of racist that's a little
racist but again what this comes down to
when it comes to crypto when it comes to
economic control
if the administration gave up economic
control if they got over they'll build
back better nonsense if they got over
the idea that the federal reserve is
supposed to be the economic
fixer of first option
then the economy would do a lot better
if the federal reserve was just there to
provide essentially a two percent
monetary increase every year which by
the way i'm opposed to as a general
matter because it means that over the
course
of 25 years half of your savings is gone
but
with that said the the
basic
notion that that the federal reserve is
there to serve as sort of a backstop in
case of a run on the banks is not a bad
idea but that's not what the federal
reserve is anymore there's a point that
the head of allianz mohamed ellerian has
made over and over and over he says that
basically the federal reserve and
centralized apparatus apparatuses
apparati like the federal reserve
control too much of our markets and this
is a bad thing the left likes that they
want that they don't trust the market
and that's where this comes in when you
don't trust the market the market
doesn't trust you and this is why you
have an economy that is performing at
less than stellar
alrighty in just one second we'll get to
joe biden's supreme court pick because
justice breyer did announce his
retirement yesterday basically they they
had one of those shepherds crooks and
the and justice briar was just sitting
there at the supreme court and they went
and they just kind of pulled him
directly off of the supreme court
he went along with it because he
understands the democrats are about to
be wiped out in the senate first 2022
could be a big year for a lot of
businesses but some industries are
projected to grow even more this year
like fitness home improvement pet
services well if you work for or own a
business in one of those growing
industries or a wide range of other
industries you probably need to hire
asap there's only one place to go zip
recruiter right now you can try it for
free at ziprecruiter.com dailywire zip
recruiter uses powerful technology to
find and match the right candidates up
with your job then it proactively
presents these candidates to you you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job which encourages
them to apply faster no wonder
ziprecruiter is the number one rated
hiring site in the united states based
on g2 ratings zip recruiters technology
is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day
right now you can try ziprecruiter for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com dailywire that's
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-ire zippercrew.com
dailywire zippercrew is indeed the
smartest way to hire in a labor market
that is really really short you need
ziprecorder right now zippercare.com
dailywire to get started alrighty in
just one second we'll get to joe biden's
totally not racist totally not
affirmative action black female pick
we'll get to that in one second first if
you didn't catch it yet latest episode
of adam crawler's daily wear exclusive
comedy series truth yeller is streaming
right now it might be the best one yet
adam takes on hunter biden is joined by
comedian tj miller who drops some comedy
gold and proves that he is the real deal
what what does that mean well head on
over to
dailywire.comwatch right now to find out
because we here at dailywear we are
producing all sorts of great new content
you need to get involved dailywire.com
watch right now to check out adam
corolla's great new comedy series truth
yeller if you're not a member go to
dailywire.com subscribe use code miller
for 25 off your membership and get ready
for some serious laughs also if there's
anybody the biden administration
mainstream media big pharma don't want
you to hear is the voice of dr robert
malone he was the guy who was on joe
rogan and you'll remember that they
basically banned him from social media
even though he's an american virologist
immunologist and pioneer of mrna
vaccines that is because of his public
skepticism of the total efficacy of the
covet 19 vaccine he went viral for that
rogan podcast in any sane society his
background would qualify him as an
expert whose opinion should at least be
heard but we are not living in the same
society and so he is being censored
which is why our very own candace owens
sat down for a three and a half hour
interview with dr malone does not leave
any stone unturned together they touch
on some of the most alarming stats
questions and trends mainstream media
and big tech do not want to acknowledge
it's an incredibly important interview
it'll be available exclusively at
dailywire.com this tuesday february 1st
if you don't already have a daily wire
membership join now to catch the newest
episode of candice premiering this
tuesday 9 p.m eastern 8 p.m central also
tune in this sunday for a brand new
episode of the sunday special featuring
my interview with first amendment
attorney harmeet dillon
harmeet represented us at the supreme
court with regard to the coveted vacs
mandate push by the biden administration
and she fights with conservative lawfare
all of the predations of the left on a
daily basis fascinating it is a
must-listen interview you can check it
out at
dailywire.comwatch or on my youtube
channel ben shapiro you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile the biden
administration is pushing forward with
its supreme court pick yesterday justice
breyer officially announced his
retirement this is after he was
basically approached from behind by joe
biden and company and pushed down a
flight of stairs here was justice breyer
announcing that he will go just in time
for the democrats to replace him because
he can read the tea leaves i mean he
sees that in november democrats are just
going to get skunked so here he was
yesterday
of course people don't agree
but we have a country
that is based on
human rights democracy and so forth but
i'll tell you what lincoln thought but
washington thought and what people today
still think it's an experiment it's an
experiment that's still going on
and i'll tell you something
you know who will see whether that
experiment works
it's you my friend
it's you mr high school student
it's you mr college student that's you
mr law school students it's us but it's
you
it's that next generation
and the one after that there he goes one
of the least consequential supreme court
justices in american history you cannot
name a single decision with justice
brother's name on it that was of any
consequence he was just a reliable vote
for the left which is all democrats are
looking for anyway well that and a black
woman so joe biden continued to
reiterate that he will pick a black
woman which again is kind of insane the
reason it's insane is because in any
other context that would just be racist
if he said i need a white male that
would be racist if you said i i need an
asian
transgender little person that would
also be sort of strange
labeling people not by their belief
system about the constitution but by
their race and sex seems kind of
counterintuitive when your entire shtick
is that you're supposedly an anti-racist
but of course we know that the ibramex
candy anti-racist folks are the most
racist people in america today here's
joe biden pushing this
the person i will nominate will be
someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
i made that commitment during the
campaign for president and i will keep
that now i'm just going to point out
right here that joe biden did vote
against clarence thomas's nomination to
the supreme court on the basis of the
ridiculously needy hill accusations also
his party filibustered the woman who
certainly would have been the first
black woman on the supreme court janice
rogers brown when george w bush wanted
to nominate her for the ninth circuit
court of appeals it was the it was the
democrats who attempted to filibuster
janice rogers brown they did the same
thing with hispanic american miguel
estrada when it came to the dc circuit
court of appeals so all of their
affirmative action nonsense to the side
the reality is what they mean is a
person who believes like we believe but
also is going to fulfill certain
intersectional check boxes so i can go
back to my constituents and i can
pretend that i care deeply about them
that's what this is really about now the
amazing thing is that the media
immediately went to full spin mode and
you could see that this was going to
happen because as soon as joe biden had
said i need a black woman everybody on
the right went okay that's affirmative
action and a violation of basic equal
protection standards like an employment
if i just said today i'm only hiring a
producer who is a white male i will not
look in any other candidates this would
be a violation of equal protection it
would also be a violation
of the civil rights act of 1964. i'm not
a government actor so it wouldn't
technically be an equal protection
violation it would be a civil rights act
violation okay but he is a government
actor which means he's violating both it
doesn't matter the media immediately has
jumped into action to suggest that
republicans are pouncing it's just it's
all about republicans pouncing so you
have aaron blake writing for the
washington post here's the title the
very selective effort to cast biden's
supreme court pick as a as an
affirmative action hire wait hold on i
don't have to cast it as that he said it
he literally said it
i mean i don't know how else am i
supposed to take i need the first black
woman
am i supposed to take that any like does
he not need the first black woman
now you'll notice that at the beginning
of this particular episode i put the
phrase black woman in air quotes the
reason i put that in air quotes is
because that's a joe biden quote
like it is affirmative action i don't
know what else to tell you
i mean they quote me saying it is
definitionally affirmative action and
race discrimination which of course it
is
but then aaron blake goes on he says
well you know there have been other
presidents who have done this yes and it
was bad when they did it ronald reagan
promised he would appoint a woman to the
supreme court in the 1980 presidential
campaign and then he ended up appointing
sandra day o'connor who was a joke and a
terrible justice
george h.w bush picked clarence thomas a
clearance thomas happens to be a really
really good justice
okay the fact that that we have these
sort of designated seats is ridiculous
it's ridiculous on its face it's really
stupid
and meanwhile jen saki is suggesting
that the gop is obliterating their own
credibility by criticizing biden's pick
well no we are criticizing him for
saying that he will only look at the
race and sex of a person
as a as a predominant characteristic and
also we think that you're just gonna
select a democratic apparatus who's
gonna do whatever you want because
that's what you guys do again democrats
never miss on this stuff because they
just find somebody who agrees with them
politically and then appoint that person
to the supreme court knowing they don't
care about the constitution
we have not put out a list the president
made very clear he has not made a
selection
and there are if anyone is saying they
plan to characterize whoever he
nominates after throw consideration with
both parties as radical before they know
literally anything about who she is uh
they just obliterated their own
credibility man talk about obliterating
your own credibility gensake every
single that should be the the title of
her autobiography obliterating my
credibility gen saki story
wow
and by the way speaking of obliterating
your credibility it is fairly incredible
that they are now attempting to go after
ilya shapiro he's been a guest on this
program of course he is from cato
institute
and now he is uh he's about to be a
lecturer at georgetown university what
did he do wrong he said quote
objectively best pick for biden is
srinivician
who is solid progressive and very smart
even has identity politics benefit of
being the first asian indian american
but alas doesn't fit into the latest
intersectional hierarchy so we'll get a
lesser black woman thank heavens for
small favors the fact that he used
lesser black women they're now saying
that he's racist what he meant is a
black woman with lesser credentials
obviously
but um you know it
none of it matters they're trying to
basically oust him from his position
over at georgetown anyway
so you have a guy named mark joseph
stern who's tweeting out he says that
georgetown law has hired him so i feel
an obligation to condemn him there's a
staff writer at slate trying to get ilya
shapiro canceled from his job because he
is making clear that these
that the administration is picking
somebody who's not well quali less
qualified at least than uh than the
person that he described there
again affirmative action for democrats
it only works one way it's not
affirmative action when they do it even
if they say it's affirmative action
meanwhile we all know the real reason by
the way that they somehow convinced
justice briar to step down the real
reason they convinced him to step down
is because they're about to get walloped
there's a brand new poll out of out of
georgia today
from the atlanta journal constitution
and the university of georgia and it
finds governor brian kemp right now up
on stacey abrams by seven points despite
all the controversy surrounding kemp
even senator perdue the ex-senator he
beats stacey abrams by four meanwhile in
the senate herschel walker is up three
on senator rafael warnock
47-44 and according to polling data
actually only 21
of georgians say that an endorsement
from trump would make a candidate
more attractive to them only 21
say that it would make a candidate less
attractive to them now you assume that
that includes you know all the democrats
but here's the bottom line
if you look at the the approved versus
disapproved ratings for various members
of the georgia delegation
they're not great for the democrats
oscar said 43 warnock is at 44. biden is
at 34.
so things are likely to get extremely
ugly for rafael warnock in georgia
before things are over meanwhile in
nevada it looks like things are really
ugly by the way it is also true that the
democrats have now engaged in precisely
the same strategy that
donald trump engaged in in the georgia
election earlier this year so george you
remember donald trump after he did not
win georgia after that happened he came
out and he said that was because of
voter fraud and your vote really doesn't
count in georgia and a bunch of
republicans stayed home for the senate
elections which is why you have now two
blue senators from a red state
and that was because donald trump
intervened and people from the rural
areas did not vote in that senatorial
election which is a foolish move now
democrats are like hey let's do it too
apparently
according to a new quinnipiac poll 45 of
black voters in georgia think it will be
somewhat or very difficult to vote
okay now how many believe that in 2020
seven percent seven percent of black
democrats sorry not black democrats
seven percent of black voters in georgia
total
said
that they thought it was very difficult
to vote in 2020. now 45 say it is very
difficult to vote how many of those
people are gonna stay home just because
they believe it's difficult to vote so
brilliant strategies here from the biden
administration just genius genius stuff
it is incredible how this administration
just keeps shooting itself directly in
the foot over and over and over again
you know if you shoot yourself in the
foot you shouldn't be surprised when
your foot hurts and that's exactly what
is happening right now and and they
can't stop won't stop i mean biden's
surgeon general literally came out
yesterday and said that he wants joe
rogan censored by big tech like i'm
sorry this is not the way you win hearts
and minds here gang
we've got to do several things number
one we've got to recognize that our
technology platforms whether
particularly social media these have an
important role to play these are the
predominant places where we're seeing
misinformation spread these platforms
have still not stepped up to do
the right thing and do enough i should
say to reduce the spread of
misinformation this is not just about
entertainment it's not just about
garnering clicks this is about people's
lives and we have seen time and time
again that misinformation costs people
their lives so you have the surgeon
general of the united states calling for
censorship of joe rogan you keep going
with this guys you have your narratives
your nerves are completely at war with
the experience of the american people
keep trying to convince them not to
believe the evidence of their own eyes
alrighty we'll be back here later today
for an additional hour of content first
you can't forget to end your week by
tuning in to the andrew clavin show
bruce shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you so head
on over to dailywire.com 7 p.m eastern 6
pm central and tune in i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high event audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
christina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin